I saw a scientific study on killing cancer cells with frequencies between 100,000 and 300,000
megahertz. That's a lot of hurts. That's a well over a million hurts, but you might be talking
about 100,000 or 300,000 hurts. Using resident frequency therapy device. I will say that there is no
resident therapy, resident frequency therapy device that goes that high. But you, what's one,
early there is a second lower input, all the 11th harmonic, which can shatter cancer cells,
the right capable of doing this. So, bleh bleh bleh bleh. So the true right is not capable of
running 11th harmonic frequencies. So I think everybody on here today, we look at everybody's names.
Everybody on here today has a true right. If you've looked at our website, you can look at the
member site lately, we are starting to use a different brand of right now as well. I still love the
true right. I use the true right at home, but I also am using another right machine called the
Atelier Robin P220 machine. I've always said that I will always stick to this that I am not tied
to any machine or any company or any brand or any other outside thing. I've only used what I think
is best for my patients. So years ago, I used, when I first started using right back in the 90s,
we used a B-brain. And then we added a top of the B-brain, we used a light beam generator and a B-brain.
I don't think true right existed then. At least, I didn't know anything about true right.
At that time, I don't think things existed at that time when I first started using the right.
But when I had the results that I had with my first patient who had bilateral breast cancer,
we used, I was using a B-brain on her and a light beam generator. So both of those. So I had two
different brands of growth. Now that over the years, I discovered true right. And I followed their
machine to be far superior than either one of those. So I stopped using the B-brain and I started using
true right. So that led me to use mainly the true right from that. I still have a light beam
generator. And I used to use it when people came to the office. Matter of fact, anybody here
on the call that came in our office at any particular time. We may have done the light beam generator,
which I think it has validity of helping move live because it's done directly on the
scale to the store. But light beam generator can be a good thing to help with live flow. It's a
different type of right. It's not programmable. So you can't run it specifically for a specific
cancer. The B-brain, I gave up using because it was, it didn't have enough power. So the true
right was about 20 times more powerful than the B-brain. So I just basically roged the B-brain. So it
had never been used again. I used the true right for, then I don't know how many years, 15, 20 years.
I can't remember when I first started using the true right, quite honestly.
But lately, the true right, I'm still happy with the true right company, even though it was bought out
by another person. I think they're trying to do things right. But I have some issues with some
choices. They're making it as well. So again, back to the droid, where I want to find if there's any
other machete out there. Well, I discovered the atelier ramen a number of months ago.
Well, one started testing it. It is more powerful than the true right. Now again,
you don't necessarily need more power than the true right because how much power do you need?
It just has to be able to penetrate your body. So for that sake, I wouldn't buy an atelier
ramen just because it's more powerful, but it does have some other benefits to it.
The board that's in the machine allows you to run the 11th harmonic. No, it's funny because I've never
talked about this. I think I've just discussed it with my staff before. We started to investigate
this new P220 machine and there's several things that intrigued me about the machine and I wanted
to test them out. I've been running this one for a couple of months now and the running 11th harmonic
frequencies have great benefit in killing pathogens and killing cancer cells. Now the true right does
not allow you to do that. It doesn't have that capability. So I'm answering the second part of this
question first. So the atelier ramen has benefits over the true right in that it has more power,
which isn't always necessary because it runs on 75 volts versus 30 volts. Secondly, it has the
ability to run the 11th harmonic, which I think is very beneficial for cancer patients and those
that aren't trying to kill pathogens. Thirdly, it has a built-in scanner and so the scanning abilities
with it are extremely accurate. So of course, it could scan themselves and create their own programs.
And then lastly, I think it has a superior footband at risk. So I've been actually working with
that company helping another practitioner develop a better bulb as well.
The treatment's opacity of a bulb is the gas that's in the bulb and the amount of gas that's in that bulb.
So true right, most of you on here have the older true right bulb. That's larger. They just changed
bulbs just in the last year where the bulb is smaller. And we're using those bulbs that were in the
process to develop in our own bulb that's larger. It's actually got a larger diameter on it. It's
longer. So it holds more gas and you're going to get more treatment to be able to be through that bulb
because of that. So there's benefits to the atelier ramen. Would it be like, oh, should I change the
atelier ramen? No, I wouldn't say that at all. My staff has asked that question.
Should I change it by an atelier ramen instead of true? I don't know that it's going to,
I don't know how much benefit is, you know, again, you get to this point of how much better
is this going to be? Well, I don't know. And it's going to be very difficult to objectively
come to any conclusions about that. So I'm not saying that. Well, one of the things that I'm
most excited about to tell you about is that it allows us to use to run any program using the
11th harmonic. And that gets into a little technicality with frequencies that I'm not going to get into
right now. But that might be what you're talking about. Actually, there's a video of a scientist who
has used 11th harmonic frequencies actually having up on our website now. I did have another
website for a while because the true I doesn't allow you to do that. There wasn't any machine on
the market that actually that a patient could use that allowed you to run the levels harmonic frequencies
and tell the atelier ramen to 20. So now that video is up there was actually a 10 talk a few years
ago by a scientist I think out of the University of Georgia, a 10 talk he did, well, killing cancer
cells using 11th harmonic. It is up on our website and it's up on the frequency healing site now as
well because how we have a machine that a patient could use that does that. First part of the question
here is using high frequencies to kill cancer cells. Now, there's no machine on the market that runs
that high of frequencies. And those that high of frequencies could actually be very dangerous.
So I wouldn't I would not run those frequencies. But there's a phenomenon if right frequencies
that you could use you could use frequencies. Let's say you wanted to run the frequency of
I don't know, let's say 100,000, right? 100,000 hurts. Well, you could run a divisible
frequency from that and get that same harmonic that's that's dealing with harmonics too
of that frequency. So you could run the frequency 10,000 at one tenth of that and get the same benefits
of running 100,000. So that's that is how right devices work to help kill cancers. You're not
running these super high frequencies that could be cell damaging, but you're getting the harmonic
of that frequency. I think Mike Tigley, who used to hold true right did a video on that. I think we
I think we saved it. It's on the right course. I know true rights scrubbed a lot of his videos,
which is a shame, but he did a talk on running harmonics that I never I never maybe I should redo
a video on that, but I never did my own video on that because I thought his video was good.
I'll just look and see if it's on the course. And I hope that helps. You are getting those higher
frequencies via a harmonic of that frequency with the true right with any with the true right for
the until you're Robin. As far as getting the 11th harmonic, you could only get that with the
until you're Robin. I guess if I was somebody listening to this and they're like, well, I don't
bother true. I'm good to say. So if you're doing well and your you know, your cancer isn't going
crazy or anything, there's no way I would switch. It's not it's not worth it. But if you were thinking
about if your cancer was getting worse or you're thinking of doing something different or changing
something as far as there because you know, call our office. And you know, I will get it to you
near cost or something like that. We'll try to do anything we can if you do want to to go that
route. So let us know. We still sell true rights. We don't I mean, understand it's I have nothing
against true right. We still work with them. Matter of fact, Jake, the new owners contacted me to write
programs for people who bought a true right through them. He wants me to write programs for true
right. They're just to put because they don't have anybody writing programs new programs for them.
So like you ever used to update your frequencies because
practitioners were sending programs in. Rodney was writing programs or him when they lost that
relationship with Rodney. And so we may be doing something with that one more than happy to help anybody
that anybody that's trying to help anybody with frequency. So but hopefully that answers that question.